house girl resumes hi welcome back to
the second son of the second high-five I
wanted to high-five him I don't
understand high five high five
oh that's awkward alright for us today
we're gonna climb this thing in Seattle
and hopefully we can do it I don't know
hey hypothetical totally what-if
question here but what would be the
explanation for how I might be able to
draw the power from some conduit say oh
I don't know Hank and not others like
one of these doop troopers my god get
try earlier hey looking for it I told
you so here reg I'm just looking for an
answer
that's awesome oh [ __ ] oh God
is that the elevator oh god damn it
look at this how [ __ ] cool is this
Oh God we're saying we have to keep
going read you loud and clear
don't push it and next time don't lie to
me okay trust your brother a little more
than that
thankfully the controls are really
smooth that's what you hello oh no we're
don't worry about me Betty at the Space
Needle Betty knows not to disturb when
I'm busy she's such a gentlewoman my BAE
Betty BAE
why are we going here exactly alright I
convenient some ventilation they're all
powers need ventilation everyone knows
this teleport I with my chain back info
I wet my came I'll guide this my mom
subdue to smoke says the greatest MLG
sniper client in the world you will all
subdue two smokers are we going up here
are we are some amazing I look my shoe
says D alright time to get out the eye
of the needle
and that must be what holds it all
together what are you gonna oh I haven't
seen you before
is that the male version of the girl
that a small army up oh they really
don't like other people playing with
their stuff yeah yeah there's this
anchor looks like it's holding all the
antennas in place I need a smoke
oh yeah feels good yeah oh hello this
huh are you looking for someone
Here I am baby
gah got a bump sound seemed delivered I
love how they shoot around the corner
like subdue him come on there we go
Moses this is really like Pokemon except
I'm joining people to my sniper clan buy
smokes
otherwise it's identical excuse me sir
thank you Allah other attack is to use
smoke it's like hey you know what we we
have this guy that keeps shooting smoke
at us
you know what we should use this smoke
attack give that guy a promotion there
we go it's coming back come to me
constipated face gives me new smoke
powers what is our new ability though a
poor guy you've seen serious pain these
guys were not here before I think they
really wanted to join my client earn a
karmic streak by subduing enemies all
right
I can subdue some [ __ ] you want me to
subdue you sir
all right i subdued enough oh my god are
we aiming for that thing I think Rama
yep I lost you did you read me I'm
getting nothing sir you nothing outside
our immediate area they're seriously
hurt take it easy a few streets in the
immediate vicinity right this dup
Stallone's the other 98% knocked out
their comm center okay you know what
they say the journey of a thousand miles
begins with a single kick-ass tag
Vanessa Carlton who said that nice but
by the way my knees all right we got the
Eagle I feel like that one makes more
sense I got the TV skull but of course
we're gonna go with the with a sniper
climb donkeys smoke smog geese reg you
see it from down there hell is that
we need a new national anthem very
escaped and she is cool
Nelson I've been asking around about the
escape bioterrorist do you think I maybe
need like a PR guy people here are
starting to call me the banner man which
a is unbelievably lame maybe not the
best idea you hanging around the space
we're out o smoker back to drive the TV
out of the city this is my district
reduce variate control do a lot of shape
alright cool let's do that bro-chachos
where should we begin I guess we can
just walk around and the awesome and
stuff join me and my sniper clan
did I just level up gosh we are
Guardians down one step closer to
becoming hero goodbye better dead than a
pop head this game is trying to have
like an anti-drug message I guess that's
good but really an ad okay so an agency
is hiding here we need to blend in to
defeat them he looks like that it's
anyone here in a DUP does anyone here
have to pee I think I found him I think
I found him Oh easy scoffing how can i
defeat him with smoke cuz I'm smoking
too so it's like what are we gonna do
there you go you [ __ ] mad
do you even brofist bro join my sniper
clan we have 3000 subscribers now
alright this is a camera quest what is
that
so we need to find the camera other this
and you gone [ __ ] sorry Oh penis all
right we got graffiti on this one [ __ ]
I know you're not a baby
dear squirrel you're a big lunch just
beautiful squirrel and don't let anyone
tell you're different
it has your eyes it doesn't have any
eyes well I'm just trying to be a
relatable here come on I love this sense
a lot in this game the graffitis that's
really cool teachers around oh yeah
what's up oh it's not a lemon at all is
it I don't know what they're called
Oh can we ride the tram that would be Oh
oh you yes
give me that a camera goodbye oh oh oh
yes no yes yes yes [ __ ] oh oh can we do
it epic jump yeah yeah whoa I'm enjoying
this way too much
Oh follow look weird that's a giant
cupcake flower my favorite
there you are your little batch goodbye
and odd I don't love the flow of the
gameplay man absolutely
/ flawless gameplay alright now that our
fitty we do the good stuff in this game
brace oh man don't you just hate when
you're on a bicycle and all the sudden
you don't have any wheels that's just
the worst feeling man a boy yeah that's
actually pretty cool
oh the vents are his wheels now I get it
that's creative as hell that's awesome
oh he's still standing there what is he
doing
uh-oh i drugged them so they're forced
to join me ultimate pal I can't supposed
to go there got it you're supposed to
join my sniper climb [ __ ] stone the
stoners oh my god but it's true Bryce
don't do drugs it's stupid why would you
do it at why would you just throw your
life away and I don't need to use stupid
puns to say that [ __ ] even though I do
love stupid puns high five high five now
one wide stay high okay we have to
destroy that thing I think before we can
progress so let's do that for tech shows
oh okay okay okay okay okay
okay it's time okay okay okay yeah sorry
I got a little excited yeah snick put a
pie snap a claim for left
oh come on it didn't explode it
high-five it
feel free to quote me on that if it
doesn't explode hi-5 overload I try some
hard to make the puns in the end that's
good can we destroy this now please put
your hand you who's shooting me would do
that
come oh yeah what are you doing
did he just seriously deny it you watch
why won't you die there you go
minecraft hey guys can I touch your
boobs I subdue this random guy because
why not oh my god
okay so I can do this one cool
there's been a disturbance nearby and
the power downs had some bioterrorist he
decided to vandalize your billboard
please hold on stay where you are we are
sending to you P troops to neutralize
that's right Oh Oh should I get out of
here
I probably should get
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he just exploded like
that
that's a male ditch so now I can fast
travel here that makes sense what the
[ __ ] was that
what just happened oh my god I didn't
click anything those the weirdest thing
ever
alright let's see if we can finally
start a [ __ ] mission it's fun to [ __ ]
around in this game babe oh my god
spider-man pretty lame right we should
call him like Ultraman or something like
that
dolphin sorry man I got hung up but I
found out there's this bioterrorist yeah
I just heard and can we please not use
the B word what bio Terran yeah you know
that's just a slur invented by the DUP
to make people scared economy man look
whatever you want to call them let's
just track him down find out what he can
tell us about Augustine and drain his
powers okay fine
and strange powers telling you it's
gonna work
alright just about the body consistent
Breyer don't check it out but promise me
in conspicuous yeah all right we finally
got a mission let's do it unfortunately
in the next episode hope you enjoyed
this episode rose and thanks for hanging
out with me today thank you for liking
and commenting as always frozen and
that's all for me now as always stay
awesome rappers
[Music]